emotional weakness no white girl disease
just dropped so I just got yelled at for
asking a very reasonable question so
there's been a lot of lies and rumors
circulating about me for a while now so
I decided let me go ahead and get the
story behind my timeliness video I was
applying for a trade school and I was
with my mom and we were on a phone call
and apparently you were out of the
program if you were late four times so I
need to know are there accommodations
for ADHD time blindness because I need
time blindness
yes it's time blindness good to know
that because if no then that would need
to be a factor in my decision whether or
not to go now let's be real when I post
the video you are an ugly woman yeah
well she has time blindness
it's terminal you're an [__] Sherman
time it's terminal blunt time blindness
everybody would know I was referring to
ADHD time blindness I really was not in
tune to how little neurotypicals know
about neurodiversity and you mean how
much normal people know about retards
here's my thing though you got all the
energy and time to learn all this
[__] [__] but you can't just get
the work on time look at her eyes that's
a crazy trick the ableism you don't you
don't have time blindness you have a
[__] a data connection with no
[__] cap on it so the time get off
Wikipedia so the time blindness to
describe look at the time there's only
one article I saw around my time in my
USA Today like a few months ago and
basically it's people have time
blindness is what they say it's I don't
it's all [__] but they claim that
it's when people don't know how long the
passing of time is but that doesn't
explain being late to something you have
a phone you have an alarm you have GPS
it tells you how long it takes you to
get from point A to point B this excuse
may have this disease was like in the
80s maybe hey
um did not one Jewish guy like prove
that time is relative yeah well but yeah
but yeah but he also had jube blindness
the story my mom lashed out
love her but everybody makes mistakes
and I just wanted to vent about it
online because I'm tired of this
neurotypical Society who does not see
your struggles so I'm flying to go
somewhere and I just wanted to know
which everybody got struggles my cousin
Kiki just lost a testicle yeah
auditions for people struggle with
timeliness ma'am a lot of people are
struggling out there in the last like
three years I've lost four people in my
life that I would happily kill a hundred
of you to bring back okay and society
would be way better balanced it's a Time
violence yes we were all dead of time
lunch well Jesus Christ it's a serious
disease it's the real pandemic
it's what I call the ghost
you know and then the person I was why
do you keep using stock footage of a
more attractive redhead so that way you
have to look at her as long get higher
higher views in the video
and then when we were done they
look at me and saying that accommodation
since every time they do that there
should be like underneath the hotter
redhead it should just be blinking
dramatization yeah and by the way the
recent accommodation for time blindness
doesn't exist is because it's not real
because it doesn't exist right that's
why there's no accommodations for it
if you struggles being on time you'll
never when you make accommodations for
the fact that I'm [__] always late
like but by the way by the way if you
struggle being on time I get it but like
as an employee as an employer
you can't you can't make an
accommodation or that because you have
shifts people have to be at a certain
time for time blindness doesn't exist
and if you struggle with being on time
you'll never be able to get a job you
know provided you're trying your
absolute best to be there see is she
crying I asked if there were any time
blindness accommodations in an interview
or Tech Talk video about this all right
can we get a non-scottish person to say
yes like your stupid generation wants to
destroy the workplace and yeah I think
that a culture where workers are just
cut off because they struggle as being
on time when there's other solutions
that we can look to I think that what
are the other Solutions there's no other
solution well no not that one I know no
no no I know one that's not violent
you're fired you're fired you're fired
we'll get samuna come on time
Jesus Christ
bro we're so [__] with this generation
like that's why Trail that's why trains
just falling off the tracks and planes
are gonna start falling out of the sky
again and it's just because everybody's
like blue why do I have to try well okay
I'm just surprised time blindness isn't
a black disease for well it is primarily
she probably caught it from one
broad of Kremlin weapon nice timeliness
you can catch that [__] in the [__]
air bro yo this black guy touched my
[__] fruit
which needs to be dismantled and then I
asked that person how can you feel good
about yourself upholding this kind of
system oh because I still have a job
I have to get back to it actually
because I'm late and I don't have time
blindness so good luck though how do you
have time blindness if you if you have a
phone with an alarm there's literally
your excuse your excuse is gone ma'am
listen I I understand where you're
coming from I asked somebody who suffers
from what you believe to be called time
blindness man it's just called not
giving a [__] yeah it's called head of a
hangover and you're supposed to be my
age when it starts kicking in you know
what I mean you're not supposed to be 20
something and go y'all don't care about
it either women will make up a disease
not to take accountability I mean the
women will literally make a fibromyalgia
chronic fatigue pain chronic fatigue
long coven yeah titled no if people
think it's okay to treat others like
this that's entitlement you know what
I'm is your bet you have a [__]
haircut blindness too with those [__]
bangs your parents should just stop
bailing you out because Nick Mullen
actually said it best when he said you
know it's chronic pain and like
fibromyalgia these are primarily white
women diseases yeah he's like and that's
because the data correlates these are
diseases like when you go I have chronic
fatigue I have to like
sleep all day man I'm just so tired all
the time it's like these are diseases of
convenience like there are no these are
diseases you wouldn't have if you lived
in a world where you had to survive I
don't even mean being chased by woolly
mammoths I just mean no parents helping
you you better pay some [__] bills
around here or you're getting thrown out
you're two weeks late on rent that type
of [__] like without because you're
gonna have home blindness if you do that
well yeah exactly so if Mama wasn't
bailing you out and Bop up up and you
were just on your own you'd get out
there and suck some dicks at least to
pay your rent and that timeline and some
clear up real quick so while I was
watching blumhouse did like this little
documentary like little mini docs uh it
was I saw Netflix now but it was called
the worst roommate ever with a little
mini docs about they're pretty some were
good somewhere bad but
ninety percent of the docs were
women
basically falling for handsome men
seeing all the red flags ignoring them
and then blaming everybody else for the
guy being crazy every single one shout
out to my pimps out there using the
lover boy method
serious videos around timeliness has
spotted up conversations within all
right Scrooge mcguck can we get to the
next part HD Community Hey listen I'm
putting it out there right now if you're
Scottish okay
you're not allowed to make content
anymore I'll make an exception for
critical Drinker because he kind of at
least Works he's at least I can
understand him he tries
um but everyone else is out including uh
what was that guy's name that the guy
with the Nazi dog I'm done with him too
thank you yeah I'm sick of him too
critical Drinker that's it he's
grandfathered in the rest of you [__]
disgusting Northerners get out of here
talk about it more so people that suffer
with time blindness don't feel alone a
lot of neurodivergent people have
reacted to myself
foreign
you didn't learn how to do your [__]
makeup after Middle School please stop
please stop
saying that I will say that as a dude
it's one of those things that I always
did kind of feel bad for women
it's like that looks like a pain in the
ass dude yeah [__] ever not this because
she's terrible at it but I mean if you
get good at makeup like when I see a
woman that's good at makeup I'm like oh
Jesus Christ you must have been in it
for like what an hour yeah this [__]
trying to be a sticky Stardust yeah this
girl is like all I'm gonna peacock but
I'm only gonna take five minutes to do
it yeah well [__] you look like a
pigeon
[__] by his [__] liquid eyeliner so
she only has to do it every other day
maybe the reason you're late is you're
always putting on your terrible makeup
yeah maybe it'll come into work late
with your face painted like Shayna
Basler [__] break break your nose
listen saying that it's only our problem
hey can you stop it is your problem to
deal with it's not society's problem to
deal with the fact that you're lazy can
we stop throwing can you stop throwing
generic b-roll of white people actually
getting work done while you're whining
about how you can't get work done
the reason the reason I agree with that
is not because
by the way didn't get fired for being
late you also got fired because you suck
you're insufferable you when you are
there you probably don't get [__] done
and you're a lazy sack of human waste
that's what it is when I was in sales I
was late all the time when I was running
clubs I was late all the time but you
know what didn't matter you call in you
go hey I'm gonna be like 10 minutes late
uh you want anything I'll grab you some
coffee and then that was it and I go hey
it's cool man take your time because
they knew when I came in
we're getting to work you know what I
mean but it's like you're probably late
and you were like I don't know if I can
do this project we're time blindness
won't allow me to and you probably I
have you mentioned being on the phone
with your mom which I bet you sat on the
phone a lot of work and yeah oh no
dalonda I can talk
I have worked with literal crackheads
that the boss won't fire because they
get too much [__] done yeah I've
statistically worked with more
crackheads that are unfucking
irreplaceable compared to white women
and I'm talking statistically I've
worked with more white women but I've
definitely worked with at least
no less than seven or eight crackheads
in my lifetime and it's always a
warehouse guy or like in the clubs it
was always the parking lot guy you go
out there keep an eye on things clean it
up watch the cars that kind of stuff
like the crackheads like
Irreplaceable I would rather have one
crackhead than 15 of them for the same
price
oh yeah I feel alone a lot of nurses
people have reacted to my takes and
saying that it's only our problem to
deal with our own symptoms so wow even
other [__] up people are telling you
that like yeah well I'll deal with it
get a grip I disagree with that it's not
because I don't have personal
responsibility I actually really do look
at this even Adam green went out and got
himself a regular job you know how hard
that is for a guy who all he does is
scream about Jews Jesus is a Jewish
trick look at him right there working in
HR so what's your excuse and I don't
really even know why people assume that
I domed it all because you you're acting
like someone who doesn't take
responsibility that's why people assume
that you don't believe in responsibility
because you're not taking responsibility
it's your [__] problem of course we
need to be doing whatever we can to
become better people and to me ma'am
I've seen I've seen like 65 year old men
with cancer go out in the snow and
shovel their driveways because they have
to get to work the next day you know
what I mean [__] is wrong with you
your eyebrows are uneven
is there a way for us to ethically
find a way to turn these people into
some kind of fuel
can we use our brain for Bitcoin mining
something right Beth Beth and all I like
that yeah like can we just fundamentally
different view on suffering I do not
believe that I feel like ground up
humans would make a good biofuel right
like it's got everything in there
oh yeah very powerful soup why not I
mean [__] The Matrix did it well boys
we can't try without grounding up the
people first so let's get after it all
right guys I'm booking us some plane
tickets to Portland let's go
all right I do not believe that anybody
should have suffer alone well yeah but
but that's not it doesn't matter what
you believe would you believe is not the
reality well every time you relate to
work all your co-workers are gonna pick
up your slack word and suffering alone
mm-hmm
one of my other favorite things that
people always tell you oh yeah yeah
you're gonna [__] die alone you know
like everyone dies alone I'll give you
married everyone everyone thinks just
because I'm married and have kids I'm
gonna one day have everyone surrounding
my bed when I'm 70 and we're all gonna
sing a song and I'm gonna die it's like
no you're gonna slip in the bathtub grab
for the [__] towel rack that's gonna
rip off the wall you're gonna break it
up and you're gonna lay there for two
days like Scott Hall that's why I have
the rest of us that's why that's why I
have a standing shower see what I mean
he's smart he's trying to plan ahead I'm
planning ahead he's got his [__] he's
got his towel rack mounted to studs yep
I'm not oh yeah they're in there you can
see you can see it from the outside of
the house he's got those concrete
anchors just to get that one day it'll
pay off
I was worth it that was worth the 800
bucks having a problem is not something
they shouldn't have to manage all on
their own notes it doesn't matter have
to or don't your [__] 19 year old
[__] you're [__] [__] life hasn't
crushed you down and it will oh and it
will because when mommy's had enough of
your [__] or she passes away You're
Gonna Be Alone and you know who's not
going to care about your [__] time
blindness you boss any no one cares
about you you're gonna that's what it is
you're a burden on society you're an
entitled [__] [__] and the problem
is you look at this and other white
women are going yes Queen you're right
we're suffering alone we're making up
diseases instead of getting jobs
you know
but no it's like the Bo Burnham said
it's like you know when I was when my
grandfather was 26 he fought in Vietnam
when I was 26 I built a birdhouse with
my mom like you we are like so far from
from anybody having to go God I have to
fix my [__] position in life I have
to do something no no no no I have time
blindness dude this like it sounds like
a made-up Futurama disease this [__]
tick tocker has taught me one thing and
that is if and when Society well just
when Society collapses and the electric
grid fails and people start eating each
other anyone under the age of like 30
years old by the time this all goes down
I'm shooting you on site I'm not even
gonna question I already know your
morals your ethics I know even if you
are a good person I know what your
youthfulness is going to be like there
is a certain level of like that that pre
like any generation that didn't have a
MySpace
is is [__] amazing I'm shooting you
on site I don't even have time to worry
about where you're coming from because
even if you're a nice person and you're
like no I mean well I'm gonna get the
[__] with time blindness who can't
[__] who can't go out and like work
on some crops for me well Marsh all
right now's a good time to announce it I
might be late because I have they just
diagnosed with bonitis oh no yeah it's a
terminal yeah it's terminal apparently
what do you should have to suffer alone
besides I was late to rumble last week
[__] where were you that with that
excuse for me where were you last week
to be fair I before you even texted me
ago
like we figured I literally bragged the
night before I'm like oh you look 15
minutes early anyway and then I hit
every goddamn every goddamn it was like
the roads look like my city skyline City
you know what I mean like it was just
like oh okay so just nothing moves we're
all we're all dying we can't I got there
early
cool dude
I didn't get any traffic oh man lots of
people commented on serious video trying
to understand what accommodation she's
looking for others were giving her tips
on how they live with time blindness
yeah where accommodations are you
looking for that's what I want to know
like what is it you need hopes of
helping her so honestly when I was
asking what I was hoping for was a 15
minutes whoa whoa whoa how do you know
what a 15 minute window is
excuse me you wouldn't know burned by
your own time blindness boom
he just did the Columbo just one more
question how would you know what a
15-minute window is I watch enough
interrogation videos well that's not
what you said in your earliest statement
to the police you said you had time
blindness hopes of helping her so
honestly when I was asking what I was
hoping for was well first off what you
should hope for is to get the grease off
your face and maybe a little bit of
proactive you're a shiny ass [__] you
are [__] greasy
baby girl I get it because I have the
same problems sometimes but you know
what I do is I take a wipe right before
night wave usually you know what I mean
if I've been working you know just real
quick get all the little excess off you
know her face has a consistency of a
really good slice of pizza
we have to dab it with a napkin a little
bit so greasy so honestly I'm in shape
when I was asking I was just hoping for
a 15 minute window or a forever window
or a seven hour I don't know time again
applied this is ridiculous this is the
[__] I love this I was hoping four was a
15 minute window and more times you're
allowed to be late and after that video
came out people have stitched and given
some really good advice about even more
accommodations like having an
expectation time that I didn't think of
they also gave tips on how to utilize
clocks and alarms even more so than I
already would there look even if I
believed your made-up disease okay
if you could look at a phone and go
I need to get up first off here's what
you do it's really simple
I'm playing along with the disease it's
fake it's made up but I'm gonna play
along with it even if this even if even
if time blindness is real right here's
what you do here's how you handle time
blindness okay
you don't need chemo for it you don't
need anything here's what you're doing
super simple
you put in your GPS how long it takes
you to get to work and you go okay it
takes me 30 minutes to get to work and
then you go how long does it take me to
get ready okay what you do is you put in
your phone and you go I'm gonna put in
this many hours before and then you get
up you get in your car you go to work
and you get there on time like the rest
of us how long does that all take like
two or three years though oh I have time
blindness I have no idea
so did I make the video she must be
terrible at baking all the cookies are
burnt
I have like she cooks I have time
blindness what are you [__] Doctor
Manhattan I wish I wish I could fling
you to Mars goofy [__] somebody take
her and put her on the meme on the
[__] Dr Manhattan
it sounds like no Arrested Development
remember they had the joke or the guy
couldn't see faces it was actually the
guy that plays Russ hanneman that was
playing him right yeah and he had face
blindness and that's a made-up stupid
the one that was dating what's her face
yeah yeah it's face blindness ever
he didn't know if she was pretty or not
he had no idea he goes I only I only see
your hair
video because I'm selfish and I think
that everyone must spend their time to
me because I don't respect anyone's time
I've grown tired of these people that
deadlines
pools and business
hire obligation
having higher schools and businesses
have a higher obligation to God
their first responsibility okay wait a
minute she's a schizo poster let's hear
her out boys to care for other people
and if those people are struggling then
they need to reach out to them and ask
okay how can we help you what can we do
to work on this so I just think that
other people's struggles and getting
them help needs to come before profit do
I think that them and their time doesn't
matter either well absolutely not when
people ask me
in the time blindness scroll and have
everybody bashing you constantly on
Twitter and Instagram and Rumble now
Rumble well you know what that problem I
could solve two problems for you right
one you could get to work on time and
probably get a little bit more done and
get made fun of less if you just got the
[__] off Tick Tock and Instagram why
does she always dress like a 2004 scene
girl like what's going on right worse
what is this what is this look what are
you doing
you have fashion blindness
he dresses like the girl the scene girls
pick on it looks like they threw her
into a Hot Topic and just shook it and
she came out
it just you you make me wish I had
blindness blindness
Testament of what the United
deal for you honey we're gonna go
through your closet if more than 15 of
your shirts have ger on them we [__]
get out you're out
algorithms political radicalization and
how the internet is influencing
I'm sorry you think the internet is
influencing your time blindness I'm
really trying to keep up here but this
sounds like a really weird episode of
Stargate and I cannot piece it together
I guarantee you that the internet
influenced your time blindness I'm
waiting for Jordy lafort so I got in
starch I'd be like well we've we've
entered a Time blindness Vortex where we
can't tell time
because when we can no longer have a
civil discussion about a video with very
little context it makes you wonder is
there even if you look if it's because
she dresses like that because she thinks
it's 2003 on the count of the time
blindness
that's okay there you go
good job very good future for our nation
what future is there to fight for
because rousing Mass amounts of hate
judging people making Mass assumptions
and being stuck in a cognitive Loop
without even knowing it and then doing
exactly what the algorithms want is seen
as normal but you know what it doesn't
have to be thanks to Sarah for letting
us share her you couldn't get a better
microphone for the voiceover
you wish her all the best for the future
many of the comments were providing
possible solutions to help Sarah like
this person who said I have ADHD
timeliness murder if I have how come
there's no men with time blindness you
always notice it's white women with
timeliners how come nobody in Africa has
time blindness
but that's what I mean Chinese people
have time blindness that's what I mean
it's the Nick Mullen thing the only
people that have these kind of made-up
diseases are the ones that have the time
and and resources and and you know the
available to to be able to do this
plans I set Google Maps as soon as they
start getting ready so you can see I set
Google Max as soon as I start to get
ready so I could see what time it'll be
yeah you know I do that sometimes if I'm
going to a new place yeah what time I
would be arriving another person
commented on their not only that do you
know you could tell Google like you know
you hit the assistant and you could be
like
uh remind uh remind me when I need to
leave to be at this place and depending
on the traffic it'll actually be like
leave now if you because with traffic
you should leave now it'll tell you to
do it
like you should just have if you want to
be an adult you should have hard out
times when you know you have to leave
right like I have rarely been late to
this show unless it was a [__] freak
nightmare out there because I know that
the like I know that if I leave at like
2 45 which is when I leave every day
that's more than enough time to get here
but most times I get here like 3 15 20
whatever but this times I get here like
3 45 whatever but it's very rare if I
leave at 2 45 that I am at all gonna be
late here so yeah it sucks you got to
make a sacrifice because there are going
to be days that you leave like there
have been days I left at 2 45 and I got
here like three and I'm like oh well all
right we'll sit here and do some prep
but it's like you leave trying to get
here at 3 15 and then it's like oh it's
sometimes it just you just fly and
you're one of those people that probably
feels like ripped that you're like yeah
I ain't getting here early now I gotta
sit at work you know what I mean it's
it sucks but get over it you have a hard
out time have a all right I can't leave
here later than you know maybe 250. so
that I'm just going to skip to where
just to see all the P let's see if it's
men or women ready woman
yeah but all those women are like
attacking her
no they're not
I always get to work no no but go back
there's a couple there's a mixer of them
because the blonde girl
the blonde girl says I have ADHD and
will literally be late for work if I
don't set an alarm to remind me to leave
so I set an alarm like so some of them
are basically going like hey do this
[__] it's golden alarm dummy